[music]
Oh okay
don't be surprised
Thank you You're the one who found this coin
Even if you don't
want to have a cruel feast, if it's for your sake
[music]
I've stopped gagging along with you
From now on, we
'll be together
[music] It's
really good
Kagaya refuses this offer
Well, if it's
your grades, it's
enough to
overestimate it.It's
boring, but it's far from this city, and
it's close to the university
.
Kagaya Did
you find something you want to do? Well, that's a
lie.
No, thank you [music] It's okay, okay, thank you
[music] It
's normal in college, it's nothing If I'm
with everyone, I'm relieved
I don't have to have a fun self
No,
I'm not pretending
not to see it.
I wonder if I got run over by a car or something? I'm a stupid raccoon dog.
I
'm
sorry I'm
going back to cleaning You
really
shined, weren't you?
My eyesight isn't bad at all Before I knew it, my eyesight was
getting better
Yes, for
some reason, my body is suddenly
[music]
And it's close
That's right  119
This smell
[music]
There's a human inside,
but
there's a monster inside of me I
don't know
how I got this power
Why is this sense of smell
And
this strange
monster's appearance
[Music]
I really don't understand Even if
it's okay to give up 100 steps and transform Why is the
costume why the dog
?
[Applause]
[Music]
What the hell is this body
?  I couldn't
do it [music] What is
this person's
[music]
Smell
What am I doing
[music]
Next news
Early in the morning today
, a suspicious fire broke out in a work shed in a logging district
Dead or injured
According to the fire department's announcement, I'm scared right
now,
why
?
I
don't have
a smartphone
.
No, no one believed me until now, so
I thought I was crazy, but you wouldn't tell me that you
were
hiding in a place
like this.I'm interested in monsters like you.
It's not the time to do something like this I have to get my
smartphone back
[music]
You're here
Monster
I was hoping that if the invitation was found out, I'd
go on a rampage at school,
but it's a bit
disappointing
Thank you for picking up my smartphone.
What is a monster?
I said this morning too, but I saw something
[music]
Oh, it seems I'm misunderstanding I'll return my
phone,
but
it's strange
ok  I was able to take a picture You
look more handsome when you transform But it's okay You can see everything around me But
what's
wrong?
If you don't tell everyone, you're a monster I
don't think it's funny I
wonder how people will react if they find out that there really are monsters Will
I become popular
and appear on TV Or will I be torn apart
like a building
?  I don't know if I wanted to hang out
with everyone like a toy while I was still alive
If I really noticed
anything,
I would be wondering what's going on with this kind of body.  Come
to think of it, I haven't introduced myself yet
, right
?
It
seems like you guys have something to do with monsters, but
if you don't know it
's fine.
I don't like it,
there are bugs, and if I let my
guard down, I'll get burned. It's my
first time.
[MUSIC]
If this situation is not embarrassing, it's force
majeure.  Well, at that time,
if I wasn't there, you would have died
.
But I finally found it
What
are you doing?
I mean, you know what this is
[music]
Won't you tell me what the hell is this?
Well, it's obvious why I'm a murderer I won't move Then let's start
again from the beginning
Well, let's start with
self-introduction
Look,
quickly, quickly
What's your name
?
It
's not my enemy, but
it's the same
beast
as
me
.  Seeking to
melt my skin Connect me
[music]
Follow
your whisper and
continue Dyeing the
heated direction
red
[music]
I don't want to leave